Oh, we’re rolling?
I'm about to take you where
the real action starts.
Let's talk.
Let's do it.
I can't tell you exactly what you're going to see
cause you will see everything.
Take one.
Action!
Hello, I am Sisi Stringer
and I play
Rose Marie Hathaway on
Vampire Academy.
And here we are in beautiful Olite, Spain.
We're in a Spanish monastery.
And we have this beautiful
castle.
And that serves as our Academy.
All of our sets have been practical
and so as actors we get to
just sort of jump into this
and immerse ourselves in the physicality of it all.
We are currently in the monastery,
but the set designers came in
and built this Moroi
dorm hallway,
for the rich and upperclass.
Tell them to go easy
on the starch.
I'm sensitive.
I have a feeling that someone's in this room.
Someone who might like
to see me.
Boo!
Aahh!
Hey! What's up guys?
I'm Daniela Nieves.
I play Lissa. Come on in.
This is my room.
I think it's so colorful to really
contrast the lifeless barracks.
Yeah, that's where I sleep.
Slumming it with the
rest of us now.
Tell us about the unicorns.
Christian has a lovely line,
where he says,
"Lissa, you really are a unicorn."
So naturally, I have seventeen
unicorns in my bedroom.
I don't need a man to save me.
Neither do I?
It's André here. I play Christian
Ozera. This is my room.
There's a bunch of books.
Christian's a big reader.
This old Moroi really is
kind of beautiful.
Spain is cool, man.
When we first got here,
it was a monastery
and some fields and
a vineyard.
And now if you check out
the set,
it's completely transformed.
Yeah, it's just- It's incredible.
It's so magical.
We see Mia a lot in Victor's
house. That's our family home.
It's very bougie, very cool.
Where else do I spend time?
A little bit in the guardian training barracks.
This is where Sonya spends
all of her time.
This set, at night,
it's so romantic.
All of the candles are lit.
This is her place.
We are at Olite Castle.
This is where we shoot a lot
of our royal court scenes.
We have an obligation to
everyone, not just the Moroi.
Obviously the costumes are
super fly. Check this thing out.
The minute I put this outfit on
and started walking around
these locations,
I knew exactly who
the character was.
Behind me, St. Vladimir's Academy.
It's just a pretty romantic
and special environment.
Do you know what
you've done?
Mind your tone Victor.
This is a sacred place.
As you can see, we're at
the church,
where we've filmed some
really incredible scenes.
I'd sooner die,
then see your family's
bloodline on the throne.
Perhaps the saints will
grant you your wish.
She's got a very great wardrobe.
Personal favorite's probably
the one I've got on now.
Because this is the first dress
that I wore in the show,
which was just so cool.
I need a favor. Can you pass
Lissa a note for me?
No way.
We're currently in the
courtyard for St. Vladimir's,
but by far one of my
favorite places to be
was the Dhampir bar. Whole
thing was designed for us
and it's also where we keep
our memorials
for all of the fallen Dhampirs.
Which, I think it's key in
this show to remember
that it is life or death
for these guys.
You're kind of a guardian nerd,
aren't you?
I'm Kieron Moore. I'm playing
Dimitri Belikov.
I'm about to take you where
the real action starts.
The fight den.
You'll see some cool lights.
Some cool fights.
I'm impressed.
Ooo, look who it is!
I play Mason Ashford. He's, um,
better than Dimitri.
Hahahahaha!
He has this undying
love for Rose.
I'm more comfortable on top.
Don't I know it.
Easy. That's my girl.
These fights are real. There is
no special effects.
Everything you see has been
performed, which is a credit
to the amazing stunt team
we have here.
That's just a little bit of what's
going on in the show.
Haha.
This whole experience is
once in a lifetime.
We have all fell in love
with these characters.
Yeah, we've built a little
family here, man.
We've built a little family.
They're not going to use
like none of this.
I need you to stop.
We're going to use all of it.